est-ce que moi je suis pour la
reconnaissance faciale la réponse est
non j'ai eu l'occasion d'exprimer pour
dire que pour un événement olympique
comme pour tout événement je ne suis pas
sûr qu'il faille la reconnaissance
faciale après sa pose la question de
quel type de société on veut je crois
qu'il faut aussi accepter de risques ce
que vraiment l'endroit où il n'y a aucun
risque que c'est pas très rassurant d'un
point de vue démocratique donc je crois
que on peut avoir ce débat bon voilà
évidemment il est toujours difficile à
tenir mais mais la croissance sociale je
ne suis pas sûr que nous ayons
aujourd'hui les moyens de garantir que
demain il ne soit pas utilisés autrement
en revanche que nous ayons des moyens de
vidéos dites intelligentes ou
d'intelligence artificielle appliquée à
la vidéo oui ça aujourd'hui la loi nous
l'interdit et je vais le demander je
vais les demander à Madame la Premier
ministre comme arbitrage je lui
demanderai si jamais c'est autorisé dans
la loi olympique c'est quoi la vidéo
intelligente c'est quand vous avez un
mur d'image et que vous recherchez une
petite fille dans la foule vous donnez
pas la photo de la petite fille que vous
reconnaissez comme étant la petite fille
madame mademoiselle X mais vous savez
que la petite fille elle est brune elle
fait 1m20 et un t-shirt jaune et la
vidéo intelligente vous ressortir toutes
les petites filles si vous recherchez un
homme qui se balade avec un couteau et
qui a des cheveux longs c'est pas pareil
que de recevoir que chercher monsieur
Darmanin vous recherchez un homme qui et
donc les caméras aide énormément à la
décision non j'ai pris cet exemple pour
pas qu'il attaque à domine bon je ne
suis je ne suis pas grand
et je n'ai pas de couteau
et je n'ai pas les cheveux longs c'est
parce que parce que j'ai laisse pas
pousser parce que sinon la police la
police peut demanderait les papiers vu
mes origines est-ce que vous voulez dire
c'est ça non mais j'ai eu des contrôles
d'identité très nombreux quand j'étais
jeune étudiant à Lille madame la satrice
non la question c'est c'est moi je suis
pour l'application intelligente des
vidéos et ça ça fait partie des
dispositions que nous pourrions demander
dans le cas d'une loijo mais je n'irai
pas jusqu'à la reconnaissance faciale
personnellement